Film Courage: I think you said earlier that
documentaries are kind of…this is their
time right now.
Why do you think now so?
Matthew Miele, filmmaker [Always At The Carlyle]:
I think because with the streaming that is
happening, they are able to get out their
to a bigger audience and there is also this
notion of a doc series that’s been popping
up and is very popular now where you can tell
longer-form things like HBO is doing things
that stretch over a few nights.
Netflix and other streamers are doing things
calling doc-series where it’s four to six
episodes of certain subjects.
But I do think that reality these days is
somewhat more interesting than what fiction
can even dream up.
I mean there are so many cool things happening
in the world you kind of have to put a magnifying
glass on it to examine it and to me we are
living in such an amazing time where there
are all these compelling things everyday.
And there’s a certain thing where you don’t
really want to chase a headline because it
will be irrelevant tomorrow.
But if you look at certain things that are
hit upon sometimes like The Carlyle Hotel
where you continue to see stories happen there,
where you continue to see history unfold,
those are the kind of things you want to grasp
onto.
For me, they are not only relevant for historical
reasons but they are constantly current.
So that’s why I think for a film like this,
something will happen with the streamers and
how accessible it will be to everyone eventually
besides the pockets that the theaters are
appealing to audience-wise because I just
feel like it’s always going to be in the
news in sense, they are always going to be
something that occurs there and that’s just
the magic of the place.
So that’s what I feel like a film like this
[Matthew’s latest documentary film ALWAYS
AT THE CARLYLE] will appeal and be popular.
Similar with Bergdorf’s, that happened.
I think is this fashion hunger out there,
people just can’t get enough of it.
And when that film came out in 2015 I think
it was at the height (I think it’s fallen
off a little bit).
I think people are kind of getting over-saturated
it.
But I don’t know docs to me I mean they
are selling, so I know there is a marketplace
for them and they are selling at a decent
enough level that you can continue making
them.
And I think that’s exciting for any filmmaker
to just continue telling your story and if
you have bidders on your content, you can’t
be in a better spot because you continue to
do what you do.
So I feel like that golden period, you can’t
really recognize it when it’s happening
but I think when we look back on this decade…I
would say from 2010 to 2020 we’ll be like
“Wow!
That was an amazing moment where we were telling
amazing stories.”
Film Courage: Plus we came out of a recession
(or supposedly we’ve come out of one) so
during that time and so it’s a relatively
inexpensive way to get a film made if you’re
doing it in piecemeal.
Matthew: It definitely is and what’s so
interesting about The Recession is so THE
BIG SHORT comes out and it kind of examines
what happened there.
And I love filmmaking like that, too.
It’s like the biopics and the journalistic
studies of things like ALL THE PRESIDENT’S
MEN and SPOTLIGHT, like those to me (if you
do them right) they feel like a documentary
almost.
So I feel like we’re in that mode of storytelling
right now more than ever where even Hollywood
is on to the notion of let’s tell real stories,
let’s tell what’s happening.
But the balance is of course that you’re
in the Marvel world…I feel like the indie
scene and the ones that are the more renegade
pictures are the ones telling the real stories
but they’re balanced well with this whole
Marvel universe where it’s this imaginative
fiction and sci fi etcetera where we are really
getting a great blend.
And I feel like (as I said) when we look back
on it we’ll be like “Wow, that was a really
great moment.”
A lot of people bemoan that the seventies
are over and that storytelling is not happening
any more.
I think it was ’66 to ’76 people look
at and the eighties had all those comedies
right?
But I don’t know, I feel like right now
we’re having a really great moment and we’ll
look back on it and say “Wow, that was terrific
to be a part of.”